اليوم استقبلنا الدفعه الثان عشر من
المصابين من الاشقاء الفلسطينيين من قطاع
غزه بدات هذه المبادره منذ حوالي ثلاثه
اشهر او
شهرين بمبادره من سمو امير دوله قطر لعلاج
1500 من المصابين من الاشقاء في قطاع غزه
لكن الحقيقه اكثر ما اثر فينا مؤخرا ان
عدد من الاسماء التي كنا نتمنى ان
نستقبلها اليوم للاسف
فقدت واستشهدت في انتظار يعني عمليه
الخروج بسبب تاخر بعض التصاريح الامنيه
هذا اكثر ما اثر فينا مؤخرا طبعا لا يخفى
على احد يعني الانهيار التام للمنظومه
الصحيه في قطاع غزه بسبب العدوان من قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على القطاع والتي
يبدو انها تستهدف حقيقه بشكل خاص
المستشفيات والبنيه التحتيه اضافه لكثير
من الاطباء وذلك بحسب تقارير منظمه الصحه
الدوليه وكثير من المنظمات
الاخرى فكان لزاما على دوله قطر وكذلك
هناك عدد اخر من الدول يقومون بمبادره
شبيهه لاستقبال جرحى والمصابين من غزه لو
في علاج في في غزه يعني انت يعني اكيد
بتعرف ايش مستويات قطاع غزه احنا عننا
قطاع غزه بالنسبه للصحه صفر قطاع الصحي
مدمر القطاع الصحي مدمر مدمر مدمر يعني
انا يوم ما اصابت هذه الطفله قعدنا خمس
ايام شايلينها على ايدينا لا حتى كرسي
نقعد عليه ما فيش سرير
لها ما
فيش
ه